Hollywood movie mogul heartburn
Weinstein is on a leave of absence from
his studio this morning after several
women alleged he sexually harassed them
act this actually judge told the New
York Times about an alleged incident in
his hotel room nearly 20 years ago she
claimed he was in a bathrobe and asked
to give her a massage or watch him take
a shower judge told The Times I said no
a lot of ways a lot of time then he
always came back at me with some new ass
The Times reports Weinstein reached at
least eight settlements each of up to a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars with
women who alleged improper conduct
Weinstein's lawyer tells CBS News quote
the New York Times published a story
that is saturated with false and
defamatory statements about Harvey
Weinstein we sent the times the facts
and evidence but they ignored it and
rushed to publish his lawyer says he is
preparing a lawsuit against the paper
Weinstein said in an interview yesterday
with a New York Post quote I bear
responsibility for my actions but the
reason I am suing is because of the
times inability to be honest with me and
they're reckless reporting New York
Times correspondent Jodi Kanter is a CBS
News contributor she spent four months
investigating this story with her
colleague Megan chewy and she joins us
at the table we'll get to Harvey
Weinstein's claims against your paper
that you were reckless but this was a
very extensive investigation on your
part Ashley Judd is the most prominent
name listed in your story but you have
many women who are speaking on the
record about allegations that they are
saying against Harvey Weinstein what
stands out to you what stands out to me
about this reporting is the pattern of
allegations we spoke to women from many
different places many different ages
most of them did not know one another
this was a 25 year time span and yet so
many of the women had similar stories
for example there's their allegations in
our story about a young assistant Laura
Madden being asked to sort of exchange
massages with Harvey Weinstein in a
hotel in Dublin in 1991 there's another
set of allegations in our story about an
assistant being forced to give him a
naked massage in a hotel room in Los
Angeles in 2015 two different places in
the world two different women
know each other whatsoever and yet the
pattern is so similar there are also
lots of settlements yes so there is a
legal and financial trail to these
allegations I think it's important to
explain what a settlement is often when
a woman feels that she's been sexually
harassed the way it's resolved if the
settlement is reached the women the
woman gets some financial recompense
however the thing that is a little more
concerning is that the women often have
to sign a confidentiality agreement
seeing that they won't tell anybody
would happened so the big question of
our story is how could Harvey Weinstein
enjoy all of this public acclaim collect
all these Oscars over the years while in
the background in private these
allegations are piling up so settlements
are part of the answer because the women
who have these stories in many cases
were not allowed to speak publicly about
them how did all this come about Jody
because you're saying that you even
started investigating Harvey Weinstein
and you're saying a lot of people knew
about this that is the question
we spoke to dozens of former Miramax and
weinstein company employees who said
that they knew that something was wrong
in the workplace either they were
victims alleged victims themselves some
of them knew stories from colleagues or
had witnessed things and then others
said that they just had this vague sort
of you know half knowledge about
something not me and quite right the
number of them who said that they did
anything is very small so I think the
question is who protected the women and
who protected Harvey Weinstein
well Jody why now actually judge said
this happened 20 years ago what has led
to this particular moment well I think
in part it's about the commitment that
the times has to telling these stories
about sexual harassment we've done
reporting in the last year we broke the
Bill O'Reilly story about allegations of
sexual harassment at Fox we've reported
on very similar allegations in Silicon
Valley where female entrepreneurs felt
they were pressured by investors and as
investigative reporters we feel like we
have this commitment to putting the
puzzle pieces together and asking the
big questions about these stories what
about the attitude of men within the
company and the board of directors it's
a great question both men and
women helped us with this reporting and
there's a really striking quote from a
guy named Marc Gill a former Miramax
executive in the story he says that at
Miramax everything looked golden on the
outside but inside it was a mess and the
treatment of women was the biggest mess
of all wine scenes attorney tells us
this that your investigation relies on
mostly hearsay accounts and a faulty
report we sent the times the facts and
evidence but they ignored it and rushed
to publish now the lawyer did not
respond to our request to elaborate on
what he sent you all but what what is
your response that that they sent you
evidence that refutes this Harvey
Weinstein in fact has called the paper
reckless what do you say to that well
first of all the story relies on a lot
of documentation on the record names of
women dates of incidents and remember
that one of our sources was internal
company records we were able to find out
that some of these allegations were
documented inside the companies and yet
never shared with the public and
arguably never addressed that well as
far as our interactions with them they
knew our story was coming for months we
shared the allegations in the story with
them before publication and they had a
chance to address them and we stand by
the accuracy and the fairness of our
reporting have other women come forward
since this story will see Jodi Kanter
thank you very much for joining us at
the table today